não faça nada para os outros
o futebol aqui é louco na época da
economia colaborativa ele vem aqui a
primeira fase que ele fala não faça nada
para os outros é faça com os outros
entre as dez maiores empresas do mundo
7 hoje são de tecnologia cinco nasceram
lá no vale do silício e san francisco na
califórnia capital mundial da inovação
não tinha time de futebol de software
então eu fui lá e criei um time como
esse pois isso como é que comece um time
de futebol do zero
bom nós criamos o time com os fãs e não
para os fãs como nós fazemos com uma
frequência absurda rap hour no
escritório do time convidávamos esses
fãs e duas orelhas uma boca ouvíamos o
que eles queriam fazer porque tínhamos
investidores temos de apple google
facebook paypal ea rússia e carros
brasileiros também só que se não tiver
fã pm todos os times do mundo os
verdadeiros donos são os fãs e quando
você envolve as pessoas no processo
criativo e você faz com elas
aí sim tem engajamento então nosso time
não tem estádio próprio nasceu agora tá
te viu tem um estágio da prefeitura mais
um processo que a gente queria jogar e
teve uma assembléia na quinta feira mais
de 200 pessoas faltaram emprego e foram
até a prefeitura mais de 50 pegar o
microfone e falar eu quero um time
[Música]
o nosso estádio
a nossa ideia que as pessoas escolham
não só onde sentar mas com quem
enfrentar certa experiência ajuda muito
se você tá com a tua família e teus
filhos ou se você está só com seus
amigos você está com clientes ou com
colegas de trabalho
então outro exemplo concreto de como nós
fizemos o time com os fãs e não para os
fãs foi que os fãs escolheram a camisa
do time esgotaram
isso funciona não só com um fã um
cliente com o aluno funciona com todas
as partes interessadas
meu maior ídolo quando era uma criança o
ronaldo fenômeno e eu acabei virando
sócio dele não time de futebol
profissional na flórida como sim rumo eu
cheguei pra ele não foi com tudo
mastigadinho olha ronaldo vem cá vão
colocar tua cara aqui nessa ação de
marketing ou aqui está o script está
aqui você vai falar de a à z
na coletiva de imprensa mundial para
anunciar que você é o novo dono do time
não foi ronaldo
você jogou no barcelona e real madrid
você ganhou duas copas do mundo eu
agrego máscara vão montar esse ritmo
junto
ele topou se eu tivesse chegado com tudo
mastigadinho não sei se ele aceitar
então essa coisa de envolver os outros
no processo criativo
lá no vale do silício a norma eu fui
descobrir que já existe as pessoas já
funcionam assim e uma das bíblias do
vale do silício é um livro chamado a
estar tanto enxuta tem dois mandamentos
principais esse livro um é m e v
p mínimo vai a bolton produtores produto
minimamente viajava o segundo mandamento
é que era hora de burin sai do prédio
vai pra rua
isso quer dizer o modelo antigo de fazer
empresas morreu
antigamente você fazia um deus não
espera um plano de negócio ia conseguir
investidores ele com esse capital atuava
em cima do plano de negócio
hoje não é mais assim primeiro você faz
um mvp o produto minimamente viável um
protótipo um rascunho e você sai na rua
segundo mandamento saia para a rua e
você conversa com fornecedores
potenciais clientes potenciais
investidores potenciais empregados até
competidor volta pro teu quarto
protelatório e melhora
então eu não estudei jornalismo e caí de
para-quedas lá na redação da revista
forbes em nova york
você tem aquele emprego porque eu queria
descobrir o que os bilionários tinham em
comum
se você for meu amigo eu mostrei pra
você
a bíblia do vale do silício têm uma das
minhas vidas pessoais que foi o primeiro
livro que escrevi bilionários o que eles
têm em comum além dos 90 antes das
vírgulas
este livro nasceu assim eu aceitei
aquele emprego na forbes para descobrir
o que os milionários têm em comum
depois de alguns anos eu achei que tinha
descoberto e mexia tanto sabe da minha
esposa contando pra ela e ela fala
português escreve um livro vai lá conta
para o mundo que a mãe do livro que
escreve um livro e se tranca no quarto
produz um calhar março e depois manda
para as editoras e reza para que alguma
6 certo não e o mvp
então o que eu fiz eu escrevi dois
capítulos e meio e fui falar fazer de
todas a que cansou tac com a minha idéia
eu envolvi os editores no processo
criativo o título do livro não fui eu
que inventei o pascual um editor que já
faz até nesse mercado há dezenas de anos
quando você envolve as pessoas sempre
faz com elas não para elas
aí tem verdadeiro engajamento não
importa o tamanho
essa determinação talento
se você não souber construir inspirará
times
você não vai ter sucesso estrondoso
então o google é uma empresa que vale
mais de 650 bilhões de dólares que tem
mais de 60 mil empregados investiu
milhões de dólares se anos no projeto
aristóteles
eles estudaram centenas de grupos de
trabalho dentro do google para descobrir
que os melhores grupos de trabalho têm
em comum conclusão número um dos
melhores grupos constrói uma segurança
psicológica para que possa haver um
encontro das mentes e todo mundo no
grupo sente que participou todo mundo
criou junto à conclusão número dois é
melhor fazer parte de uma equipe que
funciona bem do que de um apanhado de
super estrelas que não funciona como
equipe
a gente vê isso em um esporte
profissional o tempo inteiro
o campeonato atual o campeonato
brasileiro desse ano é isso aí não é o
time que tem melhores jogadores que está
em primeiro é a melhor equipe michael
jordan dizia talento ganha jogo
só que a equipe que ganha campeonato
então o meu irmão é um zagueiro do
grêmio foi eleito o melhor zagueiro do
campeonato brasileiro os dois últimos
anos ele te viu a felicidade o mérito
disse que está presente na lista dos
primeiros convocados do tite como
técnico da seleção brasileira e eu não
fiquei nem um pouco surpreso de ouvir
dele que uma das primeiras e principais
atividades do tite foi reunir todos os
convocados numa sala e perguntar para os
jogadores o que vocês esperam
da comissão técnica então muitas vezes o
chefe
basta altas horas preparando um plano
perfeito chegar à reunião
fulano você tem até data x ciclano você
tem a ver com a data y é isso que nós
vamos fazer não envolva as pessoas no
processo criativo faça com um e não para
isso é muito difícil
eu fui criado com o modelo de educação
que recebe a lição de casa e ia pra casa
fazia o trabalho em treinava uma nota
a vida não é assim
nosso super heróis eu nunca vi o spider
nã o homem aranha o 'superman' o batman
ainda na rua perguntar como é que te
ajudou os super heróis é muito simples
que eles têm que fazer para ajudar não
só que a vida não é assim binária o
grande dizia não é sábio acreditar na
própria sabedoria
então tudo que eu conquistei na vida
foram pessoas que me ajudaram
tão importante quanto que você aprende é
com quem você aprende
hoje vocês aprenderam coisas incríveis
mas são as pessoas que estão ao seu lado
que vão fazer você atingir seu objetivo
então gaste um tempo olha pra aguentar o
teu lado agora vamos fazer um estádio é
muito normal que as pessoas se levantem
a bra abracem de lado não se levanta
vamos lá todo mundo levanta levanta aí
levanta aí vamos lá
levanta levanta levanta vamos lá vamos
lá fazer levanta aí vamos lá se abracem
é o seguinte vocês
o ter o objetivo claro é muito
importante eu vou mostrar aqui um gol
independente se você gosta de futebol ou
não pense que quando esse gol
aconteceram o teu objetivo foi alcançado
e as pessoas
essa pessoa tal dado ao teu lado que
você conhece ou não que ela represente
quem você vai ajudar a conquistar os
objetivos
quem vai te ajudar a conquistar os seus
objetivos porque a vida é cheia de altos
e baixos e você vai sofrer 171 e vai
doer
pô porque os 71 dói muito
uma pessoa vai vim pra você vai falar
para faz pouco tempo você ganhou esses
alemães 2 a 0
você lembra só você tem cinco copas do
mundo
eu moro fora do país faz mais de 12 anos
e eu fico um processo quando eu encontro
brasileiro que me fala coisa como eu
nasci no país errado e critica o nosso
brasil para acertar aqui quem está
pagando seus pais que fizeram tudo lá no
brasil temos antes dessas antepassados
chegaram com uma mão na frente e outra
atrás
então continua vamos lá então galera o
meu objetivo
jorge paulo lemann um homem mais rico do
brasil falou que é só o empreendedorismo
que tem a chance de mudar o brasil
o meu objetivo é fomentar a educação
empreendedorismo nesse país e nesse
mundo
então agora eu vou mostrar um gol por
favor se abracem vamos vibrar fica de pé
fica de prefeita de pé quando quando a
bola entrar
eu quero que vocês imaginem que o
objetivo foi alcançado essas pessoas que
estão ao seu lado você vai ajudar ela
chegar no teu objetivo delas e elas vão
te ajudar a chegar no teu que elas
representem as pessoas que vão te ajudar
então tá
[Música]
na verdade faltou o gol
ah
a gol
[Aplausos]
ae
[Música]
[Aplausos]
o amor é sobrar zilei ouro com muito
orgulho com muito amor
galera não faça nada para os outros
faça um bom os outros
imagina como seria a educação se os
professores encontrasse uma maneira de
chegar para os alunos envolvê los no
processo criativo o que vamos aprender
como vamos aprender os chefes
funcionários subordinados não com o
plano perfeito o verdadeiro engajamento
acontece quando envolvemos o outro no
processo criativo faça com os outros
[Aplausos]